yeah good to go alright let's do this
alright so last talk of the day it's
kind of late
I guess everybody's a little tired so
this talk is gonna be a fairly
high-level talk I won't torture you with
lots of definitions and theorems and
proofs it's supposed to be high level
although there are some technical parts
so I'll try to wake everybody up before
we get to those parts also I guess the
instructions for preparing these talks
were that this is these talks are
supposed to be boring to experts the
only issue is that the definition of X
right well the issue is that the
definition for what is an expert wasn't
exactly clear so I hope I kind of aimed
this at the right at the right level
hopefully it won't be boring for
everybody but if it is just just I'm
guaranteed to be correct yeah so just to
make sure it's kind of nice and
interactive so for the experts in the
room you know if you'd like to jump in
and provide more information just feel
free to jump in we should this is
supposed to be like educational so the
more interaction we have the better it
is for the audience yeah so please jump
in and add more color to everything I
say it's gonna really make things better
alright so with that let's get started
so yeah so I'm gonna talk about zero
knowledge basically from discrete log
like systems whenever I say is your
knowledge in this lecture I'm gonna
refer to honest verifies your knowledge
and we'll see why that's why that's the
case in just a minute but before let's
start with sort of kind of the high
level state of the world so in these
last two days you learned a lot about
proof systems I guess yesterday you did
pcps today we learned about succinct
proofs and methods to achieve zero
knowledge and so on it turns out as you
probably have already seen there are
many many different paths to two
succinct proofs right we can go to MPC
in the head route as we just heard we
can do the PCP route even within the the
proofs systems like methods there are
different flavors whether you open up
cells in the proof or whether you answer
queries that are inner product queries
with the proof those are called
basically those lead to two different
types of of proof systems so there are
many many different approaches to
building succinct proofs and the current
state of affairs is really if you kind
of look at the different properties of
different proof systems it turns out
each approach kind of shines in its own
way yeah and there's kind of no one ring
to rule them all right there's no Lord
of the Ring that has been discovered yet
so I'm hoping one of you can actually do
this so this will be a nice result of
this semester-long program if somebody
can actually come up with one method the
dominates all method methods and that's
the one that we will study and tea and
teach and optimize so we don't have to
keep all these six different approaches
in the head and try to compare compare
them all the time okay so that's that's
your challenge I hope by the end of this
lecture somebody has a proposal for how
to do it but it's not about you know the
lecture maybe by the end of the semester
all right good so what I'm gonna show
you here is yet another approach for
providing two very short zero-knowledge
arguments I'll explain what transparent
means in just a minute so let's talk
about some of the properties of these
systems that Lisa sings zero-knowledge
arguments so we can compare them along
different dimensions yeah so we can talk
about the proof size so often we'd like
the proof to be as short as possible
remembering the blockchain applications
actually I removed all the application
slides for my talk because Mootoo did a
wonderful job so many of the
applications for these systems come from
block chains in the world of block
chains the proof kind of goes on the
chain so we'd like to make that proof as
short as possible so obviously proof
size is one parameter how long does it
take to produce the proof is another
parameter how long does it take to
verify it is the proof post quantum
secure or not and then in this talk I'm
only going to focus on systems that
require no trust and setup and let me
explain about what I mean by that
essentially you don't need to perform
any sort of secret ceremony to generate
parameters for these proof systems as is
the case for some proof systems I'm only
going to look at systems that require no
secret ceremony so everyone can verify
that the proofs are correct and they
don't have to rely on any secrets being
kept secret okay so no trust itself all
right so with that those are kind of the
parameters and then
the proofs that I want to show you today
are called bulletproof and by the way
you already know that half the trick in
this game that's coming up with good
names for the systems so yeah so bullet
proofs is a kind of a very very cute
name and so I'm gonna show you a system
called bulletproof s-- if just that you
see the parameters if we're trying to
prove knowledge of an assignment that
satisfies a particular arithmetic
circuit
let's I'm gonna let n be the number of
multiplication gates in the circuit so
yeah so the size of the circuit is the
number of multiplication gates in that
circuit plus the size of the witness
I'll let that be n and so the length of
the proof is really quite short yeah
it's basically two login it's not even
order login it's just two log and group
elements every group element is 32 bytes
so you can see that even for very large
and these proofs are gonna be like a
kilobyte or two kilobytes yeah they're
very they're actually very short proofs
in fact they're the shortest proof that
that we have make circuits yeah these
are asthma or asthmatic circuits and I'm
only gonna be counting multiplication
gates yeah in fact there are a thematic
circuits over a large field and I need
to alert the field to be large enough so
that a group of that [ __ ] order can
have a hard discrete log yeah that's
where we are the proof or work is going
to be proportional to the size of the
circuits yeah so it does it is gonna
take time to generate these proofs of
course the one downside is that the
verifiers work is also going to be
linear in the sides of the circuit so
now this is this was evals comments from
the morning what do we mean by the word
succinct so some people when they say
succinct they mean they mean a succinct
proof it's a logarithmic sized proof and
a succinct verifier meaning a
logarithmic time verification this is
not succinct in that sense it's a thing
thing that the proofs are very short but
verification does take linear time I
would actually suggest that we use
succinct for short proofs and we use
fastest inct for short proofs plus fast
verification yeah that seems to be a
descriptive set of words yeah multi-year
comment in the patch setting like the
verification would be
like meaning would be better than linear
in their work sorry yes I'll get to that
yeah I'll get that
but right now I'm focusing on one proof
yeah so that that's that's a very good
point and then the question is is this
post quantum well these systems depend
on discrete log being hard so of course
they are not post quantum and that's
kind of where we are but they require as
I said no trust this set up so one thing
that I'll come back to you at the end of
the talk because verification is is
linear time so verifying is as hard as
computing one thing that you might try
to do to alleviate this this this issue
is actually combine this proof system
with another proof system that does have
fast verification so for example I was
hoping you would mention Italy here oh
but never mind so Starks and the heroes
are basically short proof systems yeah
and sure they produce short proofs at
least asymptotically but they're much
much longer than the proofs they will
produce here but they have very fast
verifiers yeah so one thing we might try
to do is essentially general if we want
to prove a statement we can try to prove
it using one of these proof systems that
are is fast to verify but do generate in
practice long proofs and then use bullet
proofs to just prove that the verifier
accepted the the proof yeah so this is a
way to maybe combat the fact that these
proofs take linear time to verify I'll
come back to this in a bit more detail
in the at the end of the talk I have to
say this is a research problem we don't
know whether in practice this actually
makes sense or not yeah so there's kind
of practical work to do here to see
whether it's whether these compositions
work all right so what I want to show
you in this talk actually is go through
two types of proof systems the first
proof system is due to the ancient
Greeks yeah this is why it's a classic
proof system which are called Sigma
protocols so Sigma protocols stand the
word the reason they're called Sigma
protocols is because there are three
round protocols so the words the letter
Sigma kind of suggests three rounds so
that's why they're called Sigma
protocols essentially there's a message
from the prover there's a random
challenge from the verifier and another
message from the prover yeah that's a
Sigma protocol it should be yeah I was
thinking the same thing it should be a Z
protocol
but it's it's called the Sigma protocol
that it is what it is yes
oh yeah thank you good I'll fix that
later yeah please let that be the type
of comments you the type of errors you
find thank you that yeah good point
classic it's a postive would be the word
classic yes okay right so so classic
Sigma protocols you know I guess it's
doodoo when I say when I say ancient
Greeks I mean 1998 and it's close enough
thank you oh yeah I think so you should
have said see but okay so anyhow with
the Sigma protocols kind of the classic
the classic proofs of knowledge
essentially the proof size is linear in
the size of the circuit yes these are
not succinct there are large proofs and
I want to show you how they work and the
modern interpretation of or the modern
version of the Sigma protocols using
discrete log that's what's called
bulletproof and it's really kind of an
exponential compression of the proof
size we go from linear size to
logarithmic size and you wonder how is
this possible how do we how do we get
this massive improvement and the answer
is the proof themselves require more
rounds so instead of three rounds we go
to a logarithmic number of rounds so
that's if you want to view this as
interactive protocol but all these
protocols are just public Quine
protocols the only thing the verifier
sends is just random junk random
challenges that's the only thing the
verifier does in a li in the morning
actually explain how protocols that our
public coin protocols can be converted
into non interactive protocols by
deducing the challenge from a hash
function or more precisely from a random
Oracle okay and so in reality these
proofs can be sort of come all these
rounds can be compressed into a
around so that the proof becomes
non-interactive so in reality this
actually doesn't matter but as we think
of them as interactive proofs they're
logarithmic rounds all right so that's
my goal I want to show you that this is
old-style
but it's kind of dead and this is kind
of the new style and that's what people
will be are using now so let's start so
first of all what do I mean by proving
knowledge of knowledge of an assignment
to a circuit so let's fix our finite
field so let's call that f we have an
arithmetic circuit that takes n inputs
and produces an element in the finite
field like I said the size of the
circuit is going to be the number of
multiplication gates in the circuit and
here you have just one example such
circuits notice that I also allow the
circuit to use constants yeah
which will just be one and the language
that we're trying or the relation we're
trying to prove knowledge for basically
says the instance is the circuit so
that's public what the circuit is the
witness is is the assignment beta and
the Steep and the what we're trying to
prove is knowledge of a beta that makes
the circuit be true in this in this
particular case it means it makes the
circuit evaluate to zero right that's
kind of a general relation we will work
with and the goal is to provides your
knowledge arguments for this relation
yeah actually zero knowledge arguments
of knowledge and again as I said we want
to do that that in a way that even if we
make the protocol non interactive
there's no need for a trusted setup so
no ceremony to generate parameters that
contain secrets that's our goal
all right but in fact I want to do
something more general so these proof
systems these discrete log proof systems
can do more for us than just prove
knowledge of a witness in fact they
interact really well with auxilary
commitments okay so imagine that I also
have a bunch of auxiliary commitments to
some string gamma ok so gamma is another
vector vector of length n 1 and it's
somehow it just appears in the sky yeah
so imagine like on the blockchain I
already have a bunch of commitments to
this string to this vector gamma and I
want to prove properties of this vector
alright so what is the like so actually
I'll say the nice thing about these
proof systems is they can prove facts
about committed values effectively for
free you don't have to do anything to
argue that these commitments were
constructed correctly
we can directly prove facts about the
string Gama and so more generally the
language we'll be working with
or the relation we'll be working with is
the instance is going to be a bunch of
commitments they'll be some public alpha
will see you'll see why this alpha is
needed in just a minute
alpha is another vector in the finite
field here's our circuit that we're
trying to prove and what we want to do
our witness that's you here will say
there basically we're trying to prove
that the the committed value gamma the
witness the secret witness beta and this
public alpha all satisfy the circuit
okay so our witness here is again beta
is a secret with this gamma is the
committed value and R is the opening to
the commitment R is just an opening to
the commitment so we're trying to prove
these two statements exactly R everybody
with me so we're trying to prove a joint
statement on a secret witness and a
committed value that just happens to be
available the commitments just happen to
be available to us so it all fits some
public value but you'll see what alpha
is in just a minute why we need to solve
really alpha doesn't really need to be
there alpha could be absorbed into the
circuit see but it's convenient to
separate it and you'll see why in just a
second
so in reality you know you can imagine
we have a bunch of transactions say
posted on the blockchain each
transaction maybe has a commitment to a
value and we'd like to prove something
about those those commitments yeah so
that's how these commitments sort of
appear out of thin air because they're
produced by somebody else and placed on
the blockchain and we'd like to prove
basically properties on these
communitive al use possibly with another
secrets beta so let me show you some
example applications that people really
care about and if you can improve the
proof systems for these examples that
would be a kind of a big deal okay so
let's start yeah so yeah so I already
said that so let's start with our first
example so the first type of statement
that people want to prove is what's
called a range proof so what is the
range proof well we have a commitment to
some number gamma so gamma is an element
in our field and what we'd like to do
actually that we're gonna assume this is
a high characteristic field yeah it's
not a binary field so we have a
commitment to gamma and what we'd like
to do is prove the gamma lies in a
certain interval
so you can kind of see that in financial
applications on the blockchain in
particular does this is kind of a
valuable thing to do where if somebody
pays me
they might commit to the amount they pay
to me and they need to prove that the
amount they're paying is non-negative
yeah that's the main thing we want to do
prove that the amount that's being paid
that the committed value is non-negative
so that's a typical typical range proof
and so we want to generally prove the
gamma lies in some in some small
interval like this all right so how do
we do this how do we convert this into a
circuit that we can then verify well
what we do is we set we define another
witness a vector beta that's going to
contain m elements M remember it's the
number of bits in gamma so our witness
beta is going to contain m elements and
what we need to do is prove that this
beta is a bit decomposition of gamma so
what does that mean so first of all yeah
what does that mean
so gamma first of all can be written as
well it's a bit decomposition yeah so
this basically beta 0 to beta n minus 1
is the binary representation of gamma
that's fact number one I'll write this
by the way is an inner product of the
vector of powers of two with the vector
beta yeah so gamma is equal to this
inner product and second of all all the
betas are either 0 or 1 that's what it
needs to be a bit decomposition all
right so I'd like to prove that this is
the case so I'm kind of you should look
at this and you say wait a minute this
is not what you promised so you promised
that there would be one circuit that
evaluates to zero right that's what we
need to do to check one circuit evaluate
is ear oh but here you have M equalities
over here and another equality over here
here you have M plus one equality's that
we're trying to check it's not one
equality it's M plus one equality's so
what do we do we have n plus one
equality's and we want to convert them
into a single equality what do we do
well and is not an algebraic operation
we're over a finite field we're dealing
with arithmetic circuits we can only do
algebraic operations
so I multiplied them all well
multiplication doesn't quite if you
multiply them all
that's an or square and AD okay that's
interesting let's just start with ad
let's suppose we add them all up
yeah suppose we add them all up and we
ask is the sum zero does that work add
them all up and ask us if some zero is
that sound yeah I mean imagine one of
them is negative five and the other one
is five right then they'll sum up to
zero but it doesn't mean that they're
both zero so that doesn't work so what
well what else do we do how do we
combine a bunch of your qualities into
one equality we can't just add them up
that's insecure what else do we do our
circuit our absolute value is not an
arithmetic operation not polynomials ooh
somebody said polynomials that's a
brilliant idea actually generally by the
way in this field whenever you have a
problem the answer usually is
polynomials yes just keep that in mind
that's usually what happens so so right
so what are we gonna do what we'll do is
we're gonna combine all these into one
relation in the following way this is
where alpha comes in okay so we're gonna
take our random we're gonna have a
random public value alpha and now let's
look at what we do here so I take the
first relation so gamma minus this inner
product that should be equal to zero and
I'm gonna leave it as is okay now I'm
gonna add it to the second relation but
I'm gonna multiply by alpha okay I'm
gonna add the third relation I'm going
to add all the way up to the end and I'm
gonna multiply each one of the relations
by a power of alpha so essentially I
took all my relations and I multiplied
the ithe one by a power of alpha to the
I now why does that work why does that
work let's suppose that in fact this
circuit does a value to zero so the
imagine that so let's imagine for a
minute that the sum that this crazy
thing this crazy expression actually
does a value to zero I claim if that's
true for a random alpha that means all
of these relations all of these
coefficients essentially must be zero
well why is that true just lets us walk
through the arguments this is a general
technique that comes up all over the
place so I want to walk through it one
time so everybody I'm just
chanceless yeah so what we have here is
essentially a polynomial in alpha
polynomial degree n minus 1 in alpha
where their relations are the
coefficients alright and what we're
doing is we're evaluating this
polynomial at a random point alpha if
this polynomial evaluates to zero at a
random point
well the polynomial of degree m can have
at most M roots we evaluated our field
is gigantic right skew point we
evaluated at a random point and we got
zero that means the polynomial must be
the zero polynomial yeah so if this
circuit evaluates to zero at a random
point the polynomial must be the zero
polynomial which means that all the
coefficients must be 0
scalar alpha is a value in the field
alpha is like 5 7 1931 is gonna be huge
Jeff is gonna be like a 200 bit number
so f is huge if there's much much much
bigger than M yeah so the only reason I
went through slowly is to say that the
way you combine a bunch of relations is
literally by selecting one random alpha
and combining things in this way and
checking the results is zero yeah
excellent excellent question I'm it's
usually predicts where I'm gonna go next
so we kind of explained why this
actually works the question is where is
this alpha coming from so can the prove
her choose alpha well no because if the
prove are got to choose alpha he would
just choose an alpha that's a root of
this polynomial and then we'll get zero
even though it's not supposed to be a
zero it's kind of like the court the
problem that Ally had in the morning so
really where we would like this alpha to
come from is from the verifier yeah so
effectively what we'll do is we'll make
the prove or commit to all the
coefficients then the fair verifier will
produce alpha and then the prover will
prove that the circuit evaluates to zero
yeah that's kind of the general
techniques and of course like I'm it was
saying if we want to get rid of
interaction we can derive alpha from a
random Oracle right so is that is that
clear this is a general technique very
cute trick for combining a bunch of
equalities into one using just one
single
random value from the verifier so mu 2
actually has exactly the right point
which is to say we could have just taken
a random linear combination of these
relations we didn't have to go through
crazy polynomials the problem with the
randomly new combination is now we would
have to have the verifier send an entire
vector for sure for sure but now you
have to start using eventually gonna
have to prove that all these the PRG was
evaluated correctly this is much simpler
you just send one value and it's all
arithmetic that's very very easy to
prove well but it reduces diem so again
we're gonna make all these things be non
interactive so eventually the prover is
going to derive derive these things from
a random Oracle so it's it's more
efficient to basically use the random
Oracle kind of a short random Oracle to
produce one alpha
rather than to use it to produce like a
long string it's an efficiency issue
you're absolutely right we could have
used a randomly new combination it's
just more efficient to just do it with a
single element exactly exactly yeah
interactive version it's definitely more
efficient because you send less data
unless you use prgs but any after you
prove that the PRG was evaluated
correctly so that that we miss okay I
think we're I think we understand what
so let's move on so that's example
number one now so example number one is
like I said range proof this is actually
where these proofs are actually used in
practice so many of the block chains
that deal with privacy now basically
work by having the people who spend
money they commit to the amounts that
they're spending and like I said you
have to prove that those amounts are
positive and so these proofs are
actually proving this statement is
what's used in practice the classical
crime and Dawnguard method or the I'll
say they'll I'll say the classical Greek
method would have required linear proof
proof that are linear in n linear size
in M these new new methods the proof
size is logarithmic in M yeah
logarithmic in M so it's a huge
improvement over what's been done before
and I'm going to show
how this works so that's one one example
application the second example
application I want to show you is what's
called a polynomial commitment so this
is a polynomial commitment is a term
you're gonna hear a lot about throughout
this program throughout the semester so
let me explain what a poleramma
commitment is so the polynomial
commitment we basically commit to the
coefficients of a polynomial this is a
polynomial of degree n minus 1 so we
commit to the coefficients of the
polynomial and we give you two more
values in the clear it's alpha 1 and
alpha 2 and your goal is basically to
prove that if I evaluate the polynomial
at the point alpha 1 I get alpha 2 yeah
that's the statement we want to do so I
commits to a polynomial and then later
on I can open up the polynomial at any
at any point and I should be able to
convince you that the value is what I
claimed it is that's what a polynomial
commitment is ok great so how do we do
it
well the circuit is very simple we just
want to argue that this circuit is equal
to 0 you know output 0 I guess here
there's no beta even there's no secret
witness it's all there's the points
alpha and then the secret gamma the
committed gamma and we just need to
prove that this evaluates to zero so
that's a polynomial commitments now
ideally what we'd like to do is we'd
like to have short proofs yeah so the
proofs need to be logarithmic in the
size of the of the polynomial and degree
and we'd like to have fast verification
and in fact there's an old paper by yeah
Cathy I doubt that it's pro Scotty yes
ok by Katya doll from 2010 that shows
how to do this using bi linear maps yeah
so we have actually proofs that already
satisfy this very very elegantly short
commitments short proofs in fast
verification the only problem is this
requires a trusted setup this requires
what's called a structured reference
string so it does require trust I setup
we'd like to do everything with that our
trust is set up and so the answer is we
can do that we can do this without a
trusted setup using what I'm about to
show you however remember a verification
for us is linear time so the property
that we don't achieve is logarithmic
time verification our verification will
be a linear time
somebody had a question it's a one group
element yeah oh did I say logarithm yeah
the proof size was one no no I said
that's the goal they achieve even they
even they they outdo themselves they
achieve even better right the achieve
even coins one group element for the
whole proof yeah so by the way I should
say if somebody can improve these
polynomial commitments that would
actually be pretty cool
yeah cuz that's useful in sawing the
sonic proof system and then many many
other proof systems so that would be
pretty cool all right so that's example
two the third example application I
wanted to tell you about is another cute
application which is a verifiable
shuffle yeah so what's a verifiable
shuffle here I have a commitment to two
vectors yeah so I have a bunch of
numbers and a bunch of other numbers
yeah these are vectors of length and and
I want to prove that one vector is a
permutation of the other so these are
useful in mixed nets they're useful
voting systems in fact this is why this
is where these schemes come from
originally from proving that mixing of
votes worked correctly so the question
is what's the circuit to prove a shuffle
and should let me show you actually
maybe somebody has an idea how do you
prove can you give me a circuit that
verifies that one vector is a
permutation or the other yes very good
learning fast excellent yeah so here's
what we do so again what we'll do is
we'll choose a random alpha and what
will effectively do is we'll define a
polynomial that has the first set of
inputs the gamma one inputs as its roots
okay so it's a polynomial where a gamma
1 0 gamma 1 1 gamma 1 2 are the roots
and we're gonna evaluate this polynomial
at the point alpha and then we're gonna
define another polynomial that has the
second gamma as its roots and if one is
a permutation of the other you realize
these two polynomials are identical
right if one that one vector has gamma
one is its root and one vector has one
polynomial has gamma 2 is its roots and
one is a permutation of the other those
two polynomials must be the same so when
we evaluate it at a random point they
must be equal to one another and if they
are equal to one another then with very
high probability these polynomials are
and we have a proof of a shuffle it's a
cute trick and so the question basically
is how do we come up with a short proof
for the shuffle and again the answer is
using these new techniques we can get a
proof that whose size is log n log n so
if a commitment to n elements you can
prove that it's a shuffle using log and
group elements all right so that's kind
of the goals that's where we're headed
and so let's let's do it all right so
let's do it
so the first thing I want to do is
actually move away from circuits yeah so
it turns out circuits are not that
convenient to work with when we talk
about these proof systems there is a
much more elegant language to talk about
to use these proof systems called rank
one constraint systems due to Holly and
others that here's my here's my
definition of it essentially what we'll
do is we'll fix will the the computing
model is we're going to fix a bunch of
matrices a B and C so instead of giving
you a circuit I'm just gonna give you
matrices a B and C and what I want you
to prove to me is that there's a vector
X where the first element is one this is
the scalar that we allow you to use
inside of the circuits the last element
is zero this this element is going to
represent the output of the circuit okay
so this proves that the circuit
evaluates to zero at the witness and it
so happens that well this relate there's
a certain relation that's being being
satisfied so let me explain what this
relation says this circle here means
component wise product okay so we
multiply the first element by the first
element and tested that's equal to the
first element the second element by the
second element test is equal to the
second element okay so there are what is
it there are M equalities M equality
relations being tested here all right
that's that's kind of the version of our
one see yes then I want to work with and
it's actually quite easy to see that any
circuit for example this circuit can be
represented as r1 so yes let's just walk
through it very quickly what we'll do is
we'll take our witness x1 x2 so here
here's the input x1 x2 and 1 I guess
we'll put the witness at the beginning
all right and then we're going to expand
our inputs using all the outputs from
all the multiplication gates all right
so you can see
w1 is a multiplicative one
multiplication gate and w2 is the output
of the other multiplication gate right
so we add the outputs of multiplication
gates to our witness and you notice of
course the last the last element is the
actual output of the circuits and then
you can see you can pretty much see what
the matrices are going to enforce the
matrices will enforce that all the
multiplications are done correctly all
right so let's see so we have you can
look sort of at the rows here so you can
see that x1 times x2 is equal to w1
that's this gate x1 times x2 is equal to
w1 you see the w1 times x2 plus 1 is
equal to w2 yeah that's that's this gate
and so on and so forth yes we can encode
all the multiplication gates by these
matrices and that's basically how we
encode the circuits as 3 matrices so
you're gonna be hearing the term r1 CS
actually again throughout the semester
so it'd be good for you to just know
what r1 CS is and it's just convenient
for us to kind of work with it when we
do proofs on arithmetic circuits all
right so the number of multiplication
gates is what we call the number of
constraints or really what it is is just
M the number of rows and the matrices
and the number of columns is basically
the number of inputs plus the number of
multiplication gates so that's our once
yes but in fact in fact we actually want
to work with our one CS with auxilary
commitments yeah so in fact we're going
to expand the relation to take in our a
b and c but also take in additional
commitments on the outside and we're
proving statements about you know the
witness gamma and the sorry the
committed value gamma and some witness
beta all right so this is the statement
that we're actually going to prove so
far so good so this might be a little
confusing this is a little bit of a
definitional technical I mean mechanical
there's nothing interesting here there's
just a mechanical step in the talk just
so that you see what kind of languages
were going to be working with yeah
specify multiplications well the circuit
is additional multiplications
yeah we only care about multiplication
case because additions we can as you'll
see additions are for free yeah so we've
multiplications as where all the work
has to be has to be done alright so
we're gonna be building a proof system
that handles witnesses that are partly
secrets and partly committed that's
that's what's happening here oh yeah oh
yeah yeah thank you yes and W is
basically the these wires double uses
the outputs of all the multiplication
gates yes we extend our witness we take
our witness and you extend it with all
the outputs of multiplication gates and
that's that's what allows us to write it
like this
all right that's gonna cool we can
summarize an entire circuit using three
matrices and one multiplication
condition and that's it
any questions on us okay
well so what we'll do in the circuit is
we'll just literally use the matrices to
compute the additions for us so let's
look at a particular multiplication gate
the inputs to the multiplication gates
because the circuit only has
multiplication and addition gates the
inputs that multiplication gates must be
themselves linear functions of previous
multiplication gates and that's it right
there must be linear functions of
previous multiplication gates so you can
see here the input is x2 plus 1 and so
our matrix computes x2 plus 1 yeah so
all the linear gates we can absorb into
the matrices and the multiplication
gates are being verified by the rank 1
program yeah that's it it's pretty cute
- it's very convenient so thank you Ali
for doing this this is very convenient
to work with and it's kinda cute ok very
good so we're making good progress so
let's look at our first proof systems so
the first thing I want to do is again
sure we kind of the classical of Sigma
protocols and let's see kind of how they
work and how you know why there's your
knowledge and so on all right
so the first thing I have to do is
introduce kind of the basic basic
building block which is what's called an
additive homomorphic commitments yeah so
what's an additive
morphic commitments well what I'll do is
I'll focus I'll fix let's fix a
particular group of prime ordered Q and
let's let G and H be independent
generators of this group now there are
two additively homomorphic commitments
so the first one which I'll call option
2 is actually a simpler one which says
the following if I want to commit to a
field element so these are scalars
commit to a field elements using
randomness are what I'll do is I'll just
compute G to the gamma times H to the R
that's our commitment to gamma this is
called a pedestal commitment and you can
show this compass commitment is actually
information theoretically hiding
information theoretically hiding that
should be easy to see because H to the
are completely it's like a one-time pad
that's being applied to G to the gamma
so this is just an independence it's a
random element in a group independent of
gamma so it's unconditionally hiding but
it's computationally binding
computational depending on the fact that
discrete that discrete log of H base G
is unknown so it's computationally
binding if you're in a group where that
has a hard discrete log so by the way if
you have a quantum computer this this
commitment will break this will be
insecure because you'll be able to
compute a scree bug and open the
commitment in ways that you were not
supposed to because it's only because
it's only computationally binding and
the prover is gonna commit to us this is
why we end up with that arguments not
not an actual proof yeah we have to
assume the prover cannot break this
creat log so that's a Patterson
commitment and the other option is an
alga Maha commitments and alguma
commitment is basically an alga Mau
encryption of of gamma and this this
commitment is basically the other way
around
yeah so it's unconditionally binding you
can see that basically this term defines
what R is and once you know what R is
you can solve for gamma yeah so this is
actually in this is information theory
Clee constrains what gamma is so it's
unconditionally binding if we use this
type of commitments we'll get an actual
proof doesn't matter how smart the
prover is he will never be able to to
fool us because he can't he can't open
the commitments in a way that he isn't
supposed to
in this talk actually I'm gonna focus
just on these and these computationally
by any commitments because as you'll see
they actually give us what we want this
is why everything we get is just
arguments we don't get actual proofs all
right so why did I talk about these
commitments why did I define these
coming oh sorry one more thing is if I
need to commit to a vector I'll just
commit to an elements of the vector one
at a time so far so good
we don't want computationally hiding we
know what home were for commitments are
and we know how to commit to vectors why
did I call them homomorphic commitments
well it's because they have additive
properties again I imagine many of you
have already seen this so if I commit Oh
to gamma 1 and gamma 2 supposed to be
gamma 2 I can compute the sum of the two
I can commit to the computer commitment
to the sum basically by multiplying the
two commitments together yes I can
complete commit to the sum if I give you
a commitment to gamma in a scalar I can
commit to I can computer commitments to
a times gamma and if you combine these
two together what it means is if I give
you a commitment to a vector and a
matrix then I can commit to I can
compute a commitment to a times gamma
okay that's what the linear homomorphic
property is let us do so I imagine many
of you have seen this are there any
questions on this or is that clear yeah
everybody's good we're gonna use these
properties now over and over and over so
let's see how the proof system works so
remember we have our instance which is a
bunch of commitments see we have our
matrices a B and C we have our witness
our witness remember contains as beta
gamma and wires plus the witness
contains the opening to the public
commitments what we want to prove is
that ax times BX is equal to CX that's
the our one CS condition we want to
prove that we know that gamma really is
what's being committed to you in a
public point mints and we want to prove
that the final output of the circuit is
equal to zero I'm gonna call that
condition star that's what it is that's
what the proof is trying to prove for us
all right so the way we do this
classically again the prover has the int
since in the witness the verifier only
has the instance the way the classic
commitments work is actually very very
in that what we do is we basically send
a commitment to to this to this vector X
yeah this is our R so this is our
witness yeah we send the commitment to
the witness and now if you think about
what we have to do basically we just
have to prove oh sorry
we send the commitment to the witness
but we don't have to commit to gamma
because we already have a commitment to
gamma okay so we can exclude those
commitments from the the thing we send
to the verifier we just used the public
commitments this is why these systems
kind of work organically on top of
commitments and so we send we send a
commitment to the witness over to the
verifier and then all the only thing we
have to do is just using the linear
homomorphic properties both of them will
compute commitments to ax BX + CX and
then they're going to prove that
condition star holds on these
commitments that this condition holds on
the commitments that's it that's the
whole proof okay so of course somebody
should ask me how do you do this that's
an excellent question
thank you yes yeah so how do you prove
that these conditions actually hold and
for that actually if you if you just
think about this for a minute you see
you'll see that these are kind of this
reduces down to fairly basic statements
so what is this what it is we're trying
to verify we're trying to verify that
the first component of this commitment
times the first component of this
commitment is equal to the first
component of this commitment and so on
and so forth abstractly this means if I
give you a commitment to a a commitment
to be in the commitment to see you want
to prove that a times B is equal to C
all right and for that it turns out
there are very simple zero knowledge
proof yeah just to prove given three
commitments to prove that they satisfy
this multiplicative property it's a very
simple zero knowledge proof sand proof
is so this takes care of the first part
the second part just proving that I have
an opening to a commitment this turns
out to be a proof of discrete log again
very very simple proof we know how to do
this very well and to prove that this is
zero all I do is I just open the
commitment can I show you that it's a
commitment to zero all right so I was
going to show you actually how these
actual proofs were
they basically use sort of the
generalized snore protocol but I think
in the interest of time I'm gonna skip
over this there's other more interesting
things I want to show you so let me
actually skip over this and I'll just
tell you that at the end of the day with
these classic proofs you remember we had
to commit to our witness and then we
have to prove facts about our witness
just commitment to the witness just like
community the witness we already lost
right so because when we commit to a
vector we've committed a vector
component by component right so if we
have an N long vector we'll end up with
n commitments so already we have a huge
proof and then proving condition star
again gives us a linear size proof so
we've already lost just by step number
one step number two makes us lose even
more yeah so these are not these are
kind of the long proof that we want to
avoid okay so so the question is what do
we do what do we do and so this is how
we go from Sigma protocols to these
bulletproof s-- let me show you what the
trick is
yeah how do we shrink like how do we
avoid this step one somehow we have to
improve our commitment scheme so we can
shrink everything and make the proof
much much shorter so first of all I
should say that bullet proofs is due to
buddha old owl and then two boons and
Buddha little Benedict is sitting right
over there is Jonathan here thank you
yes it's funny to talk about you you
guys when you're here but that's good so
yeah so this is captured in two papers
and as well as some follow-on work so
let me explain how this works so what
was the problem with the classical
scheme in the classical scheme again if
we wanted to commit to a vector we had
to commit one element at a time so we
got a linear size commitment and that
already made our proof be linear size so
the idea to improve that is to improve
our commitments yeah so we're going to
use what's called a multi commitments
and in a multi commitments the I can
commit to an entire vector using a
single group element so let me explain
how this works sorry this is the old
commitment right so we when we commit to
one element at a time and as a result we
end up with a linear size commitments in
a multi commitment what happens is the
following we
a bunch of independent group generators
yeah so nobody knows I need the screed
log relation between these group
generators and by the way these are
because they're random there's no trust
as set up here they could all just come
from a setup procedure in particular
they could be generated by a random
Oracle that's fine and the way we commit
to a vector there's basically by
producing this this multi commitment
here so would you do G one to the alpha
one to do the alpha to G through the
alpha 3 and then we blind by H to the
arc so you see the single group element
is committing to an entire vector all
right
these again these proofs are
computationally binding assuming the
screed login the group is hard but the
cool thing is again we kind of solve our
problem in that a single group element
commits to the entire witness in one go
all right so that's that step number one
we have this multi commitment yeah so if
you see if we had to generate them if we
somehow had to give the verifier these
generators the proof would be too big if
we have to generate them by a trust and
setup well that would require trust a
set up but they're just random elements
in the group and so we can just generate
them arbitrarily exactly exactly as long
as there's no discrete known discrete
log relation so that's critical yeah
yeah so Peterson original yeah fine
that's correct yes actually no no sorry
let me take that back a minute that's
not quite correct so there's one small
difference in that the reason I call it
a commitment or a multi commitment is
because I blind
Patterson hash would not have the
blinding here yeah okay good so if you
take this away then it's a not only do
you have to keep this amount of space
actually when you generate the proof you
have to evaluate the random Oracle that
generates all these generators so this
is why you have to spend linear work to
produce the proof and linear work to
verify the proof you have to produce the
generators step number one there are
other reasons why it's linear but this
is one reason for sure
linear work linear space but the
commitment is
only a single group elements cool but
we're not done oh yeah sorry so just for
simplicity what I'll do is just
introduce some notation I'll say a
vector of G's raised to the vector of
alphas means this alright so this will
just simplify what's coming good
everybody okay with this so that's the
peterson hash z to the alpha is a hash
of alpha using base g alright so now the
question is if we have a multi
commitment to a vector
what can we prove about this vector
that's the problem yeah that's kind of
the question we have to solve
so just compress just compressing the
commitment by itself is not enough we
have to prove that star property star
holds for this multi commitments so how
do we prove properties and a committed
vector and it turns out here the problem
really just boils down to one thing yeah
the core of the blue proof system is
basically a non zero knowledge argument
it succinct but it's a non zero
knowledge argument for what's called an
inner product proof so what is an inner
product proof now please pay attention
here this gets a little bit tricky but
this if you understand this you
understand bullet proof so let me see if
I can get this across in five minutes
all right let's see so again we what is
this deepen we're trying to prove so we
have a vector of generate actually two
vectors of generators we have another
generator V and then we have another
element P the statement we're trying to
prove is that if I give you the element
P the the prover knows vectors alpha and
beta such that well if I compute the
Peterson hash of alpha times the
Peterson hash for beta am i multiplied
by their inner product then I get the
element P that's the whole statement
we're trying to prove that's the core of
the bullet proof proof systems is just
proving this type of statement I know
vectors alpha and beta that satisfy this
relation you can see why it's called an
inner product proof because I'm proving
knowledge of a commitment to two vectors
and their inner products all right now
remember this P is a single element it's
like it's kind of remarkable the single
group element that captures two huge
vectors and their inner product
yeah and we just need to prove the inner
product statement everybody with me okay
so let's do it now this is kind of a
cute proof so alpha and beta are the
witness no no nothing is given no
nothing is given all everything is
absorbed into this element P the only
thing that's given at these these these
things yeah given the witness alpha and
beta the inner product is defined and
we're multiplying by V to the inner
product yeah this is the only thing
that's given this this is a statement
and alpha and beta are the witness
that's it actually these elements G H
and V they're gonna come from the random
Oracle P is gonna be provided by the
prover these the proof yeah GP is the
instance P is the statement that we're
trying
the gym no no G&H are fixed forever yeah
these are fixed generators forever
really the only thing that changes is
pee thank you from a random Oracle just
the value of the Oracle one two three
four five and that gives you the
generators no they're not this is not
well no you could you could view this as
a multi commitment well there's no
blinding so this is a hash really yeah
in fact I'm gonna think of this thing as
a hash function in just a minute right
so we want to prove that if you think of
this whole operation as a hash function
we want to prove that we know a
pre-image of this hash value with a hash
values P all right that's the core of
the proof let me show you how this proof
works cuz it's pretty cute and then
hopefully it'll be clear alright so the
proof that I'm gonna show you has
literally just to login elements this is
where the compression comes from yeah
please yeah
it's a proof of knowledge exactly it's
not it's but the point is this short
it's it's sure it's short yes it's an
argument of knowledge
the point is it needs to be a short
argument of knowledge yeah that's
absolutely yeah yeah exactly so you want
to prove that you know it's in fact
we're gonna have to build an extractor
yeah but it's toxins from the prover but
the point is that proof itself is very
short you could always ascend the
vectors alpha and beta in the clear if
you don't care about zero knowledge just
an alpha and beta but that would be a
long poof our goal is to build a short
proof
no you shouldn't think of it like that
think of it as the instance is the
verifier basically has this P actually
both the verifier and approver has this
P this P will fall out of the statement
that you're trying to prove out of the
circuit they're trying to satisfy so
they both have P and now the prove er
wants to convince the verifier that it
has this witness alpha and beta
satisfying this condition yeah and it
has to do it that it knows this alpha
and beta so we have to be able to
extract this alpha and beta and it has
to do it with very very few group
elements actually because this is not
going to be a zero knowledge proof this
is a you know it's a sound proof but
it's not zero knowledge this P is gonna
be derived from the assignment of the
witness and the assignment of the wires
but everything is gonna have to go
through some blinding process to make it
zero knowledge yeah but for now we're
just gonna focus on this statement and
not worry about zero knowledge just
worry about the sickness all right good
please ask any any other questions wanna
make sure this what it is we're trying
to prove should be clear yeah so you
could send alpha and beta to send the
vectors off on beta in the clear but
that would be a linear size proof our
goal is to build a logarithmic sized
proof yeah that's that that's it cool so
it's this we're focusing on it's a
synchronous not and it's a synchronous
and soundness not on zero knowledge okay
so let me show you how to do it
so this is gonna be interesting yeah
let's see if I can do this in two
minutes
yeah so as we said we're gonna define
this let's define this hash function so
I'll call it the hash function based on
G H and V of alpha and beta this hash
function is literally going to be
defined there's a thing that outputs
this value okay this is just a
notational convenience so if I hash
alpha and beta I get this particular
group element it's a single group
element so that's what the verifier has
P and the prover wants to prove that it
has a pre-image of this hash function
well so the minute you see a logarithm
in the proof it's in the proof size you
already know how the proof is gonna work
right the proof is gonna be some
recursive procedure so if we're gonna
recurse what that means is we have to
break our statement into two halves okay
so how do
breakin into two halves well let's take
let's think of the left left side of
alpha and the right side of alpha and
the same thing for beta all right so
that's so if I didn't do anything didn't
do anything all I did is I just said
let's call let's break out fit off our
FL and alpha are now let's try a
strawman proposal first imagine that we
compute oh by the way we can do the same
thing to G right so we can break it into
the left left half in the right half so
let's let's imagine that the prover
sends this this hash value PL to the
verifier so this means GL to the Alpha L
times h l to the beta L times V to the
power of their inner product so suppose
we send PL to the verifier and we send
PR to the verifier as well can someone
tell me what's the relation between P PL
and PR thank you yeah exactly P is equal
to pl times P R so what the verifier
wants to check what the very fact of
this check that this product verifies
and now they need to recurse and prove
that PL and PR satisfy the same
relations but this doesn't work right
because if you recurse twice that's
going to give us a binary tree of size
of linear size so we didn't compress
anything so somehow the way all these
proofs always work this is always this
is by the way whenever you design a
proof system the first thing you should
try to do is break your problem into
halves
show that that you can break it into two
subproblems but you can't rehearse on
both subproblems what you have to do is
take the two subproblems and combine
them into a single sub problem and then
recurse on the single subproblem that's
what we'd like to do so the question is
how do we combine PL and PR into a
single sub problem this is not so easy
actually this is not so easy so I'll
just tell you there's a lemma here that
shows how to do it so let me see if I
can explain what the lemma says all
right so we have our P that's defined
using the combined vectors and the way
we're gonna come and then we have some X
X's like a challenge from the verifier
we're gonna combine the two halves into
a single instance that's half the size
is in this weird way yeah we can we
compute you know x times alpha L X
inverse times
our same thing on beta and then we then
we do the same thing to the generators
okay so we have so you notice this is
half the dimension this is half the
dimension and the generators are have
two dimension right oh yeah so here
these are half the dimension and so what
we'd like to do now is basically have
the verifier compute the subproblem
right compute the sub problem and then
we can recurse under sub problem the
problem is if the verify can't give the
Kivar the verifier given the values that
it has it can't actually compute this
value this hash value is we don't know
how to derive it from the values values
that we have so what we have to do is
give the verifier enough information to
compute this new hash and this new
information are these quantities L&R you
can see it you can think of them as sort
of cross products you can see gr is
paired with alpha R alpha L and HL is
paired with beta R yeah so these are
sort of cross product terms that
naturally come from an inner product and
now lo and behold given L&R it's
actually easy for the verifier to
compute the new hash value yeah this is
a lemma so this is just have to trust me
takes 30 seconds to prove but you have
to trust me in the business correct okay
so given L and R the verifier can
compute this new value which we're going
to call P Prime
and lo and behold now we have a problem
that's half the size of the original
problem and we can recurse right now we
just need to prove that the prover has a
pre-image of P Prime
that's the whole idea of bulletproof by
the way this is the whole idea of a lira
cursive type proof system so just
remember this is a hint every time you
want to come up with a succinct proof
you try to break your problem into two
halves combine the two halves and
recurse on the combined problem and that
gives you a logarithmic sized proof in
logarithmic many rounds so now that we
understand that so you can see how the
proof is going to work the prover sends
Ln R the verifier sends X and then
they're gonna and then the in the in one
step the prover at this point can output
alpha prime and beta prime and the
verifier can check that those values are
correct and already you see we're making
progress because these values are half
the size
the original value so originally the
dump protocol would require the prover
to send two vectors of length n now the
approver is sending two vectors of
length n over two so we're already
making progress and of course we're
going to recurse so things are gonna get
only better no absolutely right so so I
didn't convince you of anything indeed
we're not done so in fact in fact thank
you for asking the question because all
I want to do at this time is just put up
this this bubble the bubble says that if
you look at this one step protocol this
is an argument of knowledge in fact what
you can do from it is you can either
extract alpha and beta from the provers
remember he sent us alpha Prime and beta
Prime if you if you rewind and do all
the standard proof system voodoo you get
alpha and beta however there's a failure
probability there's a failure event you
might fail to get alpha and beta but if
you fail to get alpha and beta
you'll get discrete log relations this
second line is why this is an argument
and not a proof
yeah we're not actually proving
knowledge because we might fail but if
we fail we produce discrete log values
so if the screed log is hard we must be
getting this this quantity oh you would
rewind and just send different X's yeah
yeah well for you need for X's with four
X's you can recover you can recover
alpha yeah yep yep yep so that's the
that's the proof of security yeah so
actually walking through the proof is
takes a bit of work so I'm not gonna do
that now you can ask me after if you
want to see how this works we're almost
done so now you can pretty much see how
the proof is gonna how the inner product
argument is going to go we're gonna just
once we're gonna do this again and again
and again we're gonna do this log n
rounds at the end at the end now the
verifier sir the prover at the end just
has two values alpha and beta these are
scalars now so it just sends the scalars
over to the verifier and the verifier
actually checks that the alpha and beta
are correct actually what the verifier
does is it
it's peak age that you know the
generators and the final value P and it
can check that everything is consistent
that's the proof that's the core that's
the inner product argument yeah so far
so good this is just to give you a taste
and a idea for how this works yeah yeah
that's a very good question so like you
you suppose instead of combining the two
halves together we just recurse on one
of the sides and ignore the other one
the problem is in the soundness is
actually quite bad the soundness will
only be one half because the attacker
might the prove a malicious prover might
only get one the sides right and the
other side would be not right so now
we'll have sound this one half and we'll
have to repeat the proof you know a
hundred times if we repeat the proof I
hundred times the proof balls-up i
factor 100 yeah so actually low
soundness is a problem for us we want to
get negligible negligible soundness this
is a good question all right so maybe
I'll skip over this there's actually no
I'm not gonna skip over this isn't this
is kind of important if you unwind the
recursion at the verifier something
really cute pops up yeah if you unwind
like you actually ask what is the
verifier actually doing it turns out the
verifier actually is producing these
challenges these login challenges from
these challenges it's actually in a very
cute way it's producing this this linear
size vector and then it's just computing
these to linear size exponentiation this
is why the verifier takes linear time it
has to do these two linear sized
exponentiations plus some combination
some logarithmic number of
exponentiations this part is kind of
irrelevant it's only algorithmic work
this is where all the work is okay
because this is two linear linear Multi
exponentiations but it turns out these
are fixed generators these like Google
was asking these generators GNH are
actually fixed once and for all forever
which means that first of all we can
speed this up using pre-computation you
know that if you have to do fixed
generator exponentiation
you can massively speed it up and we can
also if we have multiple proofs to
verify as we will see in a minute we can
verify all of them together very quickly
just by combining these relations yes so
we'll see how that works in just a
minute
okay good so so yeah so how do we put
this to use I'm almost done let's go
back to range proofs so this is our
range proof basically what we're gonna
do is this is the bit decomposition beta
our bit decomposition we're gonna look
at the vector beta minus 1 yeah we're
gonna subtract 1 from everything because
we need to compute beta 0 times beta 0
minus 1 and what the prover will do is
he will send the commitment a multi
commitment to the beta L and they are in
the classical classical schemes that
commitment would be linear size because
we have to commit to every bit
individually here with a single group
element we commit to all the bits at
once this is not your knowledge we're
not done yet
that's very important so far I'm
blinding this so this part is your
knowledge this is just a random group
element so that's easy to simulate yeah
I blind I blind these these bits and now
it turns out now what I have to do is
prove you know prove that you know this
is a bit decomposition and that all the
internet all the values are actually and
that this is really all the bits are
really zero one so that's what we have
to prove and again this part I have to
say it's kind of mechanical I'm not
actually going to show you this is like
it's kind of this you know what is it
call that kind of cliche in this in this
area that once you have a sound system
adding zero knowledge is actually quite
easy we just have to add blinding
factors so really all we do is we're
gonna mask these beta L and beta R
vectors and then commit to the masks
yeah so it turns out that's what makes
it zero knowledge and of course we
combine all the qualities into one using
the methods that we saw at the beginning
and that's all I'm gonna say about that
yeah so the core of the proof was the
inner product arguments once you have
the inner product argument everything
else is kind of mechanical so sorry but
that's all I'm gonna say about that so
the end result is we get a range proof
for n bits n bit ranges that's a size to
log in so like I said very very very
short to long again compared to linear
before but this gets really interesting
like Musa was asking this gets really
interesting if we have multiple range
proofs yes if we have multiple
commitments and we want to prove
D commitments and we want to prove that
all of them are within a certain range
well the circuit size is n times D n
times D we take logarithms of that and
really this just becomes an additive log
the term so if I have a thousand range
proofs that I want to do just think
about this this is kind of remarkable if
I need to do a thousand range proofs the
proof is the same size as a single range
proof plus log of a thousand plus ten
additional group elements yeah so do so
this is kind of a little surprising I
think verification time is linear that
we can't hold we can't do anything about
verification time is linear even in the
bad setting where verification will be
linear yeah because you have to derive
these vectors this vector s to do the
multi exponentiation yeah but the proof
size like even if you have a thousand
proofs to do the proof size only grows
by log a thousand group elements you add
ten more group element and you've done a
thousand of them at the same time so if
the witness for all these thousand range
proofs are is held at one party there's
one party can generate the full proof
otherwise if the range proofs itself is
going to split
committed committed values a split among
parties we give a simple NPC to actually
generate the full proof so you can even
generate it in a distributed fashion all
right so this is kind of the the the
important property of these schemes so
just to drive this point home let's look
at some graphs so a single range proof
using traditional Sigma protocols takes
four kilobytes using bullet proofs a
single range proof this is I think 64
bits range proofs takes 672 bytes by the
way I'm comparing it to snarks the
snarks are 188 bytes but Snorks remember
require trust I set up yeah so not quite
in the same model so the proof is four
kilobytes versus 672 bytes if I need to
do two proofs the traditional methods
grow linearly our methods only grow by a
few elements yes it becomes 700 elements
and then if you need to do like ten
proofs again the traditional methods
grow linearly where as we grow you know
very very very little all right so
that's kind of just to show you how
these things
grow and then they've been in the
interest of time I'll skip this I'll
just say that in fact there's ways to
batch verify so you can verify many
proofs together at the same time so this
is the Sigma protocol so the Sigma
protocol is traditional Sigma protocols
are quite large they're linear this is
basically a linear line whereas this
line that you can't see is the
logarithmic line so it looks like a
straight line yeah okay so you can see
these proofs are about a kilobyte
kilobyte long I'm gonna skip this you
can verify a lot of them together
quickly just in the interest of time and
finally I'll say that even if you look
at beyond range proofs if you look at
arbitrary circuits again snarks are
always constant sized snarks are always
always 188 bits by bytes but neat Trust
is set up these proofs again you can see
they don't grow very much
right this is a logarithm line so they
remain even for what is it this crazy
number of gates they're only like two
kilobytes it's probably out of date so
I'm not gonna say okay good so that's
that's the point of that and so yes you
can see even for like practical circuits
the proofs are like 1,300 bytes but of
course they take a long time to verify
yeah so verification is linear so
they're actually quite slower than then
snark so there's a cost to not having
trusted set up okay I'm gonna start
basically done basically done okay so
one of the cool things by the way in
working on block chains and kind of the
technology for block chains is they do
cool stuff so I guess you kind of
declare success for your work when
actually somebody actually puts it on a
t-shirt
this is actually the actual protocol and
a t-shirt I don't I'm not wearing it
today but it's kind of a cool t-shirt to
a good material so kind of a good good
thing to wear to the gym
oh there you go yeah right so nobody
I've warned this to the gym a couple
times and nobody asked me what the heck
this thing is so it's kind of kind of
disappointed all right and so just to
summarize basically this is a great time
to be doing crypto lots of very deep
deep work that's like 30 years old is
actually being being deployed and
protecting lots of money so it's kind of
cool to be working in this area some
interesting open questions like none of
none of what I told you is post quantum
secure so can we can we have a version
that's that is post quantum secure
jonathan has been doing a lot of work on
that but the proofs are much longer than
what I showed you so this is a really
interesting open problem and then we
don't really have a reason to believe
that login is the best we can do for for
range proofs maybe we can have even
shorter range proofs and that would be
really useful the folks in Manero and
grin and all these other projects would
use that right away so if you have ideas
for how to do shorter range proofs this
is of you know like immediate practical
value so that would be quite influential
so I encourage you to actually try to
think of even better range proofs than
what we have
but for these projects it's absolutely
vital that there's no trusted trusted
setup yeah they don't want to do a trust
a setup so the question is can we beat
it with no trusted setup
all right awesome so sorry one last
thing is they have to advertise I'll go
into advertising mode and then I'll stop
so in February we're running our you
know our blockchain conference the call
for papers is out at the sites SBC 20
submit submit talk proposals and yeah
please come so please submit and it's a
technical conference on blockchain so
we'd love to see everybody there and I
will stop here so thank you very much
[Applause]